the only way we could argue is the only  definitive dance that you could have is  if you had a exact female replica to be  like she likely would not get where he  is that's the only way we could argue it  right so it doesn't want to take away  from his effort so it doesn't take away  so then why do we why do we talk about  it at all if you can't if you have no  idea why there's a pay Gap  yeah yeah like like it's is it possible  that industries that women pick because  if you if you look at the countries that  have more choice so if you go to like  the most egalitarian countries there's  more of a pig app rather than less  because women choose jobs with people  and then use jobs with objects